from the moment the world heard malaysia
airlines flight mh17 had crashed in a
ukrainian field in july last year
killing everyone on board two
overarching questions remained
unanswered how did it happen
and wide now only one is outstanding
after a 15 month seven nation
investigation we now know how mh17 was
forced from the sky flight mh17 crashed
because of the nine m31 4m warhead
detonated outside the aeroplane the best
the left side of the cockpit this
warhead fits the kind of missile that is
installed on the buk surface-to-air
missile system as a result of the
warheads detonation thousands of small
preformed metal objects were ejected
this tremendous force several hundreds
of them hit the aeroplane the impact
killed the three crew members present in
the cockpit at that moment and cost
structural damage to the forward part of
the airplane as a result of the
detonation the forward section of the
airplane broke off after which the
airplane broke up in the air the tail
section probably crashed before the
center section this center section is
also contained the engines hit the
ground upside down and caught fire the
break-up resulted in a wreckage area of
about 1550 square kilometers
almost two-thirds of the 298 passengers
and crew on the Boeing triple7
were Dutch so it was the Dutch who led
the international investigation team at
an Air Force Base in the Netherlands
aviation experts spent three months
painstakingly piecing together on a
specially manufactured frame debris
gathered from the countryside in an area
of eastern Ukraine close to the Russian
border near Donetsk
we're at the time of the crash there had
been fierce fighting between Ukrainian
government forces and separatist militia
backed by Moscow which brings more
questions
why was the airliner flying over a war
zone and who fired the missile that blew
it out of the sky
sixty-one operators from 32 different
countries flew above the area on the day
of the crash a total of 160 flights had
operated above the eastern part of
Ukraine until the airspace was closed
after the crash every single one of
those operators thought that it was safe
there was undeniable an armed conflict
taking place on the ground but above
32,000 feet that is approximately 10
kilometres the airspace was open to
civil aviation nobody considered the
possibility that civil aircraft at
cruising altitude were at risk in the
early afternoon of July the 17th 2014 a
Boeing triple7 200 of Malaysia Airlines
departs Amsterdam Airport Schiphol for
kuala lumpur malaysia flight mh17 enters
Ukrainian airspace at an altitude of
33,000 feet following airway Lima nine
eight zero the crew diverts a short
distance to the north to avoid some
thunderstorms when returning to the
airway in the eastern part of Ukrainian
airspace in this region an armed
conflict between the Ukrainian
government and armed groups is in
progress therefore lower levels of the
airspace are restricted for civil air
traffic flight mh17 is routed above this
restricted airspace to waypoint romeo
november Delta in the Russian Federation
until that moment the flight proceeds
normally the investigation team even
modeled the missile strike itself and
the devastating effect it would have had
on the superstructure of the aircraft
and the doomed passengers and crew
inside it a buk surface-to-air missile
can reach an altitude of 80,000 feet
exceeding the flight altitude of flight
mh17 by far at 20 minutes and three
seconds past one this warhead explodes
to the left and above the cockpit of
mh17 about 800 preformed fragments
perforate the aeroplane
this impact combined with the blast of
the explosion causes the cockpit and the
business class section to separate as it
descends the aeroplane disintegrates
according to the investigators report
the three flight crew in the cockpit
died immediately the missile struck the
high-energy objects that perforated the
aeroplane were also found in the bodies
of three crew members seated in the
cockpit the preformed fragments have
distinctive shapes cubic and bowtie
shaped and were made of a ferrous metal
some fragments had traces of aluminium
and glass on them proving that they had
perforated the aeroplane from the
outside the two left windows of the
cockpit particularly show perforation by
preformed fragments for the others on
board MH 17 we can only imagine the
terror of those who may have survived
the initial impact the investigation
team has attempted to apply scientific
rigor to those imaginings they were
exposed to extreme and many different
interacting factors they say abrupt
deceleration and acceleration
decompression an Associated mist
formation decrease in oxygen level
extreme cold strong air flow the
aeroplanes very rapid descent and
objects flying around it was not
possible to ascertain at which moment
the occupant died the impact on the
ground was not survivable it's likely
that the occupants were barely able to
comprehend the situation in which they
found themselves
the Dutch report goes out of its way to
avoid pointing the finger at those
responsible for the targeting of a
civilian aircraft but in the 15 months
since mh17 was brought down there have
been repeated and persistent claims that
it was a Russian supplied missile fired
by separatists who thought the airliner
was a military jet this amateur video
from shortly after the crash apparently
shows panic in militiamen rifling
through the wreckage and personal
effects of the dead as the reality dawns
on them that they've shot down a
passenger plane it certainly wasn't the
first aircraft they detect in that area
last summer in the month before the
crash at least 16 military airplanes and
helicopters were shut down in the
eastern part of Ukraine Ukrainian
authorities were aware of this they
stated that occasionally weapon systems
were used that could reach the cruising
altitude of settle airliners yet despite
all this Ukraine did not close its
airspace
even though Russia was part of the
international team of investigators
Moscow has already rubbished the final
report calling it biased
and the Russian arms manufacturer Alma's
auntie that makes the book missiles
disclosed the findings of its own
reconstructions and possible scenarios
even before the official Dutch report
was published the results of our
experiments have entirely refuted the
conclusions by the Dutch commission
about the type of the rocket and the
place of the knowledge their conclusions
the missile could not have been fired by
Russian or separatist forces but instead
came from an area controlled by
Ukrainian government troops the missile
itself was an old model they say no
longer used by the Russians
when there was the whistlin in my year I
personally have no doubts that it was an
operation which was planned by Russian
special services to bring down Malaysian
Airlines civil plane flight mh17 it was
made from territory which was under the
control of Russian rebels and there's no
doubt that drunk separatists do not know
how to operate book systems it means
those systems were operated by
professional Russian servicemen only
despite the denials there is an ongoing
criminal investigation into the attack
on MH 17 and prosecutors now say they've
identified what they call persons of
interest that they haven't said who they
are or where they are they have they'll
let it be known that their inquiries
which were expected to be concluded by
the end of this year will now drag on
into 2016
for the families of those who perished
on the Malaysia Airlines flight there is
some comfort in knowing finally what
happened to their loved ones and that
they're unlikely to have suffered for
long they are still for now denied a
definitive answer to who murdered them
at 33,000 feet
you